all right well thanks for everyone for
joining me I know that there's like a
bunch of different sessions going on and
like I'm having a hard time planning
what I want to do so I'm glad that
you've come to this if you want to
follow along you can grab the slide deck
at my speaker deck a personal page
little disclaimer at the beginning this
is going to be a little bit of a novice
presentation so if you're a black belt
and scikit-learn or pandas like you
might not get a whole lot out of this I
promise it sprinkled some things
throughout the presentation like so
everyone will get something out of this
presentation but this is really meant
for beginners or novices to this kind of
stuff no problem so what does the
presentation look like the meat of the
presentation will be three flavors of a
logistic regression before we get to
that actual patty we've got to do a
little bit of preamble so I've got an
introduction some motivation and data
creation so the bun just a little bit
more about me I work for a company
called Baro well which is a thin tech
company in Canada we've been around
since 2015 essentially we help Canadians
make great decisions about their credit
so we launched in 2015 with a personal
loans consolidation product where you
can borrow up to $35,000 at like 5.6
percent APR and this is meant for people
to consolidate their expensive credit
card debt just last year we launched a
product where we were giving away credit
scores for free this for the first time
in Canada and really kind of cool we've
got two hundred and fifty thousand users
now and we kind of wrapped up those two
different products and have helped one
of the biggest banks in Canada CIBC
whose mascot is that Percy penguin there
so CIBC has eight million customers and
we helped deliver these two products to
kind of a broader audience
essentially what I'm getting at is like
we're an incredibly data rich company
I'm so happy and thankful for the data
that you get to play with
essentially what I do my day job is a
classification problem it's predicting
yes and now it's predicting if we give
you money will you give that money back
to us so I wanted to rewind just a
little bit and kind of explain how I got
to borrow on the first place because it
kind of sets up this presentation nicely
I think this path might be familiar to a
lot of you but when I started my
professional career I was essentially a
spreadsheet jockey so I was creating
vlookups pivot tables and this was all
primarily done in Excel back in 2013
word clouds were all the rage and I
remember one of my bosses coming to me
like hey max can you do one of those
like cool word clouds like yeah I can
probably figure that out and so I
figured out that our was like a really
good tool to do that I still kind of
used Excel on most of my work and most
of my data analysis but then one day I
was throwing the data set that was like
a gigabyte begging like oh my goodness
how am I going to soar excel at this
problem and like just kept breaking and
shutting down it wasn't working so this
is when I got like really deep into R
and E sort of discovered it like R is
kind of a languages excel without the
mouse on steroids and so I kind of have
matured to the point where I'm doing
type a data science and type B data
science these are just two different
varieties for the a meaning like you're
now analyzing so if you do data
discovery or like you're presenting
insights to management you probably use
like a type a data science workflow but
I'm also kind of merging over and doing
a lot of more type B work but this is
the real machine learning stuff and more
recently I'm building out microservices
for Barwell to kind of deliver real time
machine learning products back into our
regular application flow and so right
now my stack kind of looks like this I
use R for my type-a stuff a little bit
of the type B but if I need to do
building and real work that's what
Python is for and so I don't necessarily
see the two languages as substitutable
if you guys are familiar with our you're
probably familiar with the tidy verse
and like everything that has Lee Wickham
has created like I adore the guy and I
use all of these packages kind of in
tandem with my workflow in Python so
moving more into the Python specific
stuff if I need to build a model if I
need to deliver that model I'll probably
use like castor scikit-learn
or I'll use bottle and glass to actually
deliver that stuff so this is what my
path kind of looks like it's not exactly
linear although I went from Excel to R
to Python I'm kind of like rotating back
and forth in between Python and R I
don't want to get rid of the are stuff
that have built up because like I find
that it's just it's better for plotting
it's better for web scraping I'm sorry
I'm sorry if I'm going to start a flame
war but like I I just really loved to
rely on our for the simple stuff when I
was moving a lot of my stack over to
Python though there was an hiccups so
you get used to are you get used to the
way things are done and I was kind of
looking for some of those bridges that
allowed you to move your stack from our
to Python and I noticed that Patsy the
library actually sponsored by PI data is
like incredibly good for that kind of
stuff so we're nearly to the code before
we get there I'm sick and tired of
people showing iris datasets that's
there like hello world example so I
thought we'd do a little bit something
fun today is actually Canada's 150th
anniversary I'm super bummed that I'm
not going to be there for it
so if there are any Canadians in the
crowd like come talk to me and let's
like figure out how to celebrate tonight
but essentially once you build it a
dataset that would kind of celebrate
Canada Day so let's imagine that there's
pool of migrants there's a thousand of
them they can either choose to go to
Canada or so the United States and if
you go to Canada you get a 1 so this is
just a classification problem so stuff
that I do every day I would like to
maybe show you some of the loan examples
but like you guys probably wording
it's kind of boring I love to talk about
it but like this I think will be a
little bit more exciting and to make it
more exciting I've embedded in this
dataset certain characteristics so if
you like beer you're going to come to
Canada
we've got great beer if you like warm
climates you're not going to come to
Canada it gets quite cold so you're
going to go to the States
and if you've got family in Canada
already you are probably going to come
to Canada as well so let's get into this
if you're following along and you've
grabbed the slides off my speaker deck
everything is meant to be runnable and
I'm actually going to post the link to
my github so you can actually run this
stuff in a notebook but here the
standard imports and here's how you
actually create the data so this is just
a thousand different people you're
grabbing three different inputs so beer
whether or not someone likes the warm
climates and whether or not they have
families of beer and warm is from the
normal distribution family is just one
in zeros then I'm kind of building out
that linear combination to like fake my
data to have these certain
characteristics so someone is going to
come to Canada if they really like beer
don't like warmth and have family in
Canada so push that through the inverse
logic function and then I'm going to
fake out kind of a categorical variable
at the very end so that makes sense
everyone's falling so once we've created
the data we can stuff that into a
panda's data frame and this is what it
looks like
so just examining a couple different
rows you've got on the first or index 0
someone who didn't come to Canada so
their love for beer wasn't all that high
they did have family in Canada but
they've just like really loved warm
climates and so they went to the Unites
it's someone that index 3 really loved
beer had family in Canada we really
didn't really like warm Qantas but
didn't have family in Canada they still
came to Canada so this is what the
dataset looks like I'm going to drop it
out to CSV and actually plotted in R
because like I hate but essentially this
so you can like kind of feel what the
dataset
like this is what it looks like so
you've got importance of good beer on
the x-axis importance of warm climates
on the Y you can see all the Blues are
people that once those states and all
the reds are people that want to Canada
so now we're actually at the meaty part
I said I was going to show you logistic
regression in kind of three different
flavors I'll quickly speed through the
our example the Python and then I'll
actually talk about Pasi so given that
my job is trying to figure out okay we
give you money are you going to give it
back to us I really like to start
building my models with the logistic
regression just kind of that benchmark
like it's super interpretable super easy
to build super easy to explain
especially if you're trying to sell this
stuff to investors they can understand a
logistic regression because like it's
just one step above like a linear
regression like y equals MX plus B you
can't get any more basic than that so
this is what the flow looks like in our
I hope everyone can see that essentially
when you open up here our studio ide or
whatever text editor you have you're
going to load up a tiburce just always
do that we're going to grab the data and
then split it into our tests and
trainsets so I'm using care to do this
and I'm just having my 8020 split in
this next slide we're actually going to
build fit and like just bake the model
and so this is it it's one line you're
drawing from the general linear model
with family binomial and you're
describing a model and like this really
elegant formula syntax so hey I want to
build this with just a regression model
predicting Canada on top of beer warm
and family like that's amazing if you
actually start to want to like diagnosis
model and peek at it what it does you
can see that it this is the printout of
the estimates for the coefficients the
p-values if you want to go stargazing
well like Oh like great everything looks
significant if you want to predict on
top of that model we're just going to
grab the predicts
action with model and our test data and
then to actually verify these findings
like this is not an exhaustive list but
here's one way you can do it I'm just
using a rocker so and then calculating
the area under it like I'm pretty happy
with these findings so this is the
entire flow pretty simple quite elegant
and the formula part is what I think is
most important so as I was moving a lot
of my stack over to Python given that
I'm doing with my machine learning in
this kind of paradigm now I ran through
a couple of issues and so here's the
flow that I was trying to get to work
and it didn't quite work so kind of
one-to-one we're going to load up some
modules loading the data and then this
is where it kind of like veers off
course if you're used to R and not
Python you've got to like create the
design matrix with your x-ray and your Y
output variable you like manually add an
intercept then actually like call in the
model and then oh wait no it won't work
because you've got this category with
categorical variable like that just was
automatically working for you and R so
you got to start again so load up the
models the modules load up the data
you've actually got to like dummy the
data so use some one hot encoding uh now
this is going to work so we're just
going to grab family equals yes so two
ones and zeros for that create the
design matrix and that the intercept and
then I actually really like this from so
I could learn the Train test split I
think this is a really elegant way to do
it I wish our had something better than
carrots create data partition bring in
the model fit it which is new like
that's a two-step process where an R was
just one I find that a little strange
and then you can kind of like peek at
the results of this model and grab the
same kind of coefficients and p-values
so again for view this is what the our
flow
like pretty elegant I really love that
formula syntax the Python example if
you're doing this for the first time or
you're moving your stack over from R to
paisan
is a little bit more confusing there's
like some hiccups that you've got to get
used to especially creating that design
matrix and especially like building the
model and then calling CID so I think it
kind of sucks and I'm not the only one
this is a really great Twitter exchange
that I just grabbed so someone's
complaining about logistic regressions
and specifically a bit like diagnosing
it and grabbing certain outputs I love
it because Jake van der plus actually
chimed in on this thread and said hey if
either R or Python were universally
better we wouldn't be having this
discussion I think that's like
especially true but the most important
thing in this thread is like just this
tweet right here like hey I sort of be
aggressive but I'm just trying to avoid
are in the specific instance and that's
kind of like how I feel I don't want to
avoid are all times but sometimes just
have everything in the same flow
everything in the same script it's just
better and so again using logistic
regression as a benchmark I wanted to
kind of like marry the are stuff with
the Python and pasties deserve a really
great way to do that so Patsy for those
of you that don't know is a Python
library for describing statistical
models it's building that convenience or
rather bringing over the convenience of
our formulas to Python so this is the
github page for it if you want to check
it out basically to install pepin spell
Patsy super easy and this is what the
flow starts to look like so bringing in
the modules so from Patsy import D
matrices and build design matrices that
second part is important for actual
predictions you're loading up the data
and then this is where the Python flow
kind of again looks like that our full
that you might be used to so I'm calling
D matrices and I'm just describing what
I want it to do so hey give me Kanda on
top of beer
firm and family again we're trying to
predict flows of migrants and whether or
not someone's going to go to Canada or
the United States if they like beer
they're going to come to Canada so the
one caveat rather again this is what the
our example looks like one caveat is you
need to grab that
Y output and kind of empty Ravel it so
that it plays nicely with the
scikit-learn API can I like got a
flatten it out but then the flow goes
back to maybe what you're used to in
Python so grabbing the train test split
actually modeling it so grabbing
logistic regression from second learn
linear model and then actually calling
fit on your training data to actually
peek at the results of this model you
need a bunch of different things
traditionally you'll probably grab the
accuracy score or the rock score or area
under the curve score pretty happy with
those results you can also do some cross
validation scoring so you use like a
tenfold validation and pretty happy with
that stuff or you can output your
confusion matrices or your
classification report so this is I think
pretty great this is my first bonus so
those of you that are perhaps like a
little bit more advanced like oh my
goodness like this is so basic I really
love the elegance of a raw curve but
when you're trying to explain
classification results to someone that
maybe doesn't deal with this type of
data every single day this is confusing
it might not really make sense to people
and so I'm an incredibly visual person
and I like to show people things that
they can like touch and feel and so
instead of a raw curvy actually
presenting this type of data you can do
what's called a separation plot and so
this is meant to show how well your
model does in separating the ones and
zeroes so basically line up all your
values your predicted values from 0 to 1
and then you color those on the true
values so you can see Oh at the very
tail end near the zeroes there were
people that were predicted to go to
Canada but never did and so
this normal hat does pretty well in
separation if it was just like a
completely random model this is what
look like and so that separation plot
function is just something I built I
won't go through the code but it's there
if you want it maybe I should build this
into a proper library but essentially
just like rearranging the values in an
ordered sequence and then building out
some like matplotlib code so again I
think this is a really elegant way to
show your results to people that are
maybe not familiar with this type of
stack so going back to the patsy example
when we were actually building the
design matrices patsy was doing a lot
for free it was kind of creating the
matrices but then it was actually
dealing with the categorical variables
for us and so when we actually want to
predict on top of this stuff we need to
call design and fro from the X ray and
actually start to like build out a
function so that we can predict on top
of that so if you've got new data let's
stuff it into a pandas dataframe build
the design matrices from that design
info and put in the new data and then
you can like return the probabilities of
someone coming to Canada so this is like
Bob
he really likes beer doesn't really care
for warmth and has family in Canada you
throw those values into the patsy
predict function that we built right
here and so the output is okay hey he's
got a ninety-nine point eight percent
probability of immigrating to Canada
this is like Jane she doesn't doesn't
really care for beer kind of likes the
warmth but has no family in Canada so
again calling the Pats predict function
with the design and so that you're
grabbing from the X ray that you created
and then stuffing in the values and
finding that hey she's only got a 14%
chance of coming to Canada so she's
probably going to go to the States so
this is what the flow looks like in its
entirety it's a lot more simple a lot
more elegant and it's especially great
if you want to show non-technical people
your your flow like hey this is that one
line when I'm doing the work I'm Garrett
grabbing Canada on top of a beer warmth
family and it's pretty great so this is
just kind of scratching the surface of
what Patsy can do there's also some like
really nice built-in functions where you
can like do inlining inline data
pre-processing so the data that I was
using was already kind of like
pre-processed there's cheating a little
bit just so you could speed this example
up but if you want to like center or
standardize your variables in kind of
this formula syntax you can do it really
easily and then if you actually want to
grab interactions between your different
data so you've got inputs a B and you
want the interaction vampy you can just
describe it in this like really great :
syntax so to actually extend this
example because just Patsy is probably
not enough the Patsy maintainer
Nathaniel J Smith really wants to be
Patsy to have Patsy be like the bridge
for people coming over to our and so
he's trying to developers use it in
their packages to make that process a
lot easier
so think about like Matt live what that
was it was like trying to break MATLAB
people over to Python like I see Patsy
in the same light so if you're developer
maybe the use of stuff because you can
kind of grow your audience and although
the communities of Python and our don't
really overlap it would be nice to have
like a little bit more cross-pollination
because like the ideas in both
communities are pretty great this is my
like lame attempt at using the Patsy
library and like a simple function so I
mentioned like I hate that pub I wanted
just like an easy scatter plot and so I
can say hey give me Canada on top of
beer and warmth and like kind of plot
that this is kind of pathetic though the
PI and XIII people have actually taken
Patsy and I've done a lot better job in
building at a more robust way to
integrate these formulas into what they
do so for those of you that don't know
pine c3 is a Python package for Bayesian
statistics I think everyone should be
basin's like talking about p-values and
especially explaining p-values to like
people that are non-technical is just
like it doesn't work if you can talk
about like credible intervals and
probabilities that's something people
like understand but pints pie mc3 has
its own learning curve and so what's
really great is the developers of this
library have actually built in Patsy in
kind of this like from formula method
call so you can grab hey let's build
this logistic regression and kind of
this Bayesian paradigm and grab Canada
and predict on top of beer once and
family
I'm not defining the priors but you can
but I just find passing to be like a
really great springboard to introduce
people to the more complex like Bayesian
statistics so after you build that model
you can draw from the post series and
see like what your weights are actually
doing get some outputs where you're
actually describing what the
coefficients are and giving you the
credit credible intervals which are just
like way more easy to explain them
confidence intervals but yeah so in
summary I may be your flow kind of looks
like that this where you've come from
Excel to R to Python and you don't want
to give up our or maybe like you're
coming from Python and one not
understand our a little bit better and
especially if you're a Python developer
and want to bring more people from the
our community over I think it's really
important to like build these bridges
and like figure out the next map plot
led to kind of migrate people over
Patsey I found has been like pretty
great for that I just want to give too
thanks to Nathaniel J Smith who's the
actual maintainer of this package and
for PI data and enum focus for having me
here I hope you guys got like maybe
something of this presentation yeah
that's pretty much it if you want to
find out more about me
I'm just max Humber at all these places
and if you have kind of come over from R
to Python I'd love to hear your story
and like how you've made that transition
and if you're Canadian or just want to
celebrate Canada today with me like come
to up so thank you
[Applause]
heeey
so the question is like can you do some
more robust like mix modeling with this
type of thing and I'm sure you can is
just like the models that I'm building
at work kind of don't really use
logistic regressions like this is my
benchmark and I'm kind of describing
them all first and if it performs better
than something that is like super easy
to explain I'll use those if you want to
do that mixed modeling I think i MC 3
has really great ways to describe those
kind of stacks and interactions I'd
refer you to their documentation if you
want to mix partners are why not just
call off from pipe why are apart - yeah
so the question is like why not just
call our from Python and you're
absolutely right so in Jupiter notebooks
there's a really easy like ipython magic
to grab you from arm Python or even
calling it is easy I find that like if
I'm trying to deploy my models to like a
development environment just having it
in this one flow just reduces a lot of
overhead like it's maybe not the best
example but yeah I'm just using now
Patsey as a way to kind of bridge into
these other technologies especially PI
and c3 and there's like Bambi and Edward
that I'm making use of the same
technology so although this is like a
pretty rudimentary example it's like
your question could be why not just like
drop the data out into ggplot and like
I've done that but like sometimes you
just want to stay in the regular Python
flow I don't know it's a lot of super
great answer
that if I remember correctly you use our
for the simple stuff could you elaborate
on simple in what way
I simple in the way that I define it
maybe so I really like our for plotting
ggplot is just I think really nice
I really like our for web scraping
especially like using Arvest like I've
tried beautifulsoup and although like
you can get it to work I find that it's
more elegant in that kind of our
paradigm so if I'm just doing like
simple toy examples I'll do that and if
I need to explain model results or just
like toy around with different ideas
I'll start and our and then maybe move
over to Python the opposite perspective
and my view historically I mean the more
complex models have been implemented in
are much earlier and also Python is
getting there you have to keep in mind
that the depth of implementation taking
care of all the corner cases and having
just machine learning but like advanced
time series models oftentimes there's
more in are so my perspective was always
Python is a full programming language so
as soon as I do some productive programs
I use pipe I always thought that well
for the advanced models I would want to
choose our yeah I I can't disagree with
that so the question is like isn't our
meant for more of that complex stuff and
yeah probably but again like I really
wanted to emphasize this talk is like a
way to kind of get more of that
cross-pollination so if you're a Python
person passing might enable you to think
about these are the ways that our
designs and builds up these machine
learning models like a lot of packages
use this formula notation and if you're
going the other way thinking about
Python in these terms is may be helpful
just to kind of make that click that hey
our
a lot for free if you want to create the
design matrices you've got to do it
manually but I think like more
cross-pollination is great like I'm not
doing advanced time series in our I have
but I just find that right now my flow
is mostly Python because I'm building
those micro services and the machine
learning models on top of that it's just
kind of where I'm at cool well thank you
guys
[Applause]